das Grundrecht auf Asyl abschaffen
freibadtäter binnen Stunden verurteilen
und die Grünen als Hauptgegner in der
Ampel die AFD ist stark wie nie wohin
aber entwickelt sich die CDU wird sie
deutlich konservativer gründe genug für
ein Gespräch mit dem CDU-Vorsitzenden
Friedrich Merz und damit herzlich
willkommen zum ZDF sommerinterview aus
Arnsberg im Hochsauerland
[Musik]
einen schönen guten Tag Herr Merz
willkommen im Sauerland willkommen zum
ZDF Sommer
begrüße ich jetzt eigentlich den
CDU-Vorsitzenden oder den Chef der
Alternative für Deutschland mit
substantiv-vorsitzenden und Vorsitzenden
der Bundestag sagt ja dann herzlich
willkommen wir sind in Arnsberg einen
schönen Kloster wedinghausen für ein
CDU-Vorsitzender ist die Welt ja hier
eigentlich in Ordnung es wird seit
Beginn der Bundesrepublik CDU gewählt
aber die Zeiten ändern sich wir hatten
jetzt am Wochenende eine Umfrage AFD 22
%. das bietet die AFD was die CDU nicht
bietet wir müssen uns nicht an der AFD
sondern wir sind größte
Oppositionsfraktion im Deutschen
Bundestag damit sind wir die Alternative
gegen diese Bundesregierung und wir
müssen Konzepte liefern Vertrauen
gewinnen auch zurückgewinnen und das ist
ein schwieriger Weg ich habe mir nie
Illusionen darüber gemacht wie schwierig
der Weg ist und wir sind jetzt seit
anderthalb Jahren ganz gut unterwegs
aber
wir müssen noch zulegen sie haben gerade
den Begriff noch mal gebraucht mit der
alternative viele in ihrer Partei sind
ja nicht so richtig glücklich damit die
sagen wir sind CDU mit Substanz und
sonst nichts ja und als Opposition ist
man Alternative zur Bundesregierung
immer jede Pause Opposition ja auch
umgekehrt wenn wir in der Regierung
wären wäre jeder andere die Alternative
so ist Demokratie es gibt eine Regierung
und es gibt zu dieser Regierung
natürlich eine Alternative für
Deutschland in Deutschland für
Deutschland gut wir haben einiges zu
besprechen
[Musik]
Regierungskoalition schwächelt die drei
ampelparteien kommen nicht mal auf 40%,
aber warum sind die abwandernden Wähler
nicht auf den Weg zur CDU
die CDU die Union hat sich nach der
verlorenen Bundestagswahl 2021 gut
konsolidiert wir haben die Rolle
angenommen
Opposition im Deutschen Bundestag zu
sein und jetzt arbeiten wir daran
verloren gegangen das Vertrauen
zurückzugewinnen scheint bisher traurig
Vertrauen verliert man schnell aber
gewinnt man nur langsam wieder zurück
das ist ein mühsamer Weg und darüber
waren wir uns immer im Klaren aber es
scheint doch diese 28 % scheint wie eine
gläserne Decke zu sein wir lagen im Juni
schon mal über 30 es hat dann einen
kleinen Rückschlag gegeben aber davon
lassen wir uns nicht Behren wir machen
unsere Arbeit die nächste Bundestagswahl
ist in gut zwei Jahren und bis dahin
sind wir besser sie haben zuletzt im ZDF
heute schon mal eine ganz klare
Brandmauer Beton zur AFD jedenfalls auf
Bundes und Landesebene die Wirklichkeit
in den Gemeinden sieht dabei ja anders
aus wiecher hat uns das einmal kurz
zusammengefasst
Friedrich Merz betont gern Grundsätze
auch den von einer Brandmauer zur AFD
mit mir und uns nicht doch diese
Brandmauer bröckelt längst im Fundament
in den Kommunen zum Beispiel hier in
Thüringen denke ich fand den Begriff von
Anfang an bescheuert wenn ich ehrlich
sein soll was soll das die Brandmauer
geht bis zum Dachgeschoss und im
Dachgeschoss ist es dann wieder nicht
mehr da und dann springt der Brand es
ist Blödsinn es gibt in dieser Stadt
kein rotes kein grünes kein schwarze
sagt kein gelbes schlag doch es gibt den
Schlagloch und wir sind dafür gewählt
miteinander zu reden wenn sie dann von
der AFD da sind habe ich mit ihnen auch
zusammen zu arbeiten also Brandmauer auf
unserer Ebene gegenüber überhaupt nicht
auch gibt es einzelne AFD mit dem man
vernünftig zusammenarbeiten kann warum
nicht
die Realität hat die CDU längst
eingeholt Friedrich Merz kann die
Brandmauer seiner Basis nicht mehr
diktieren
die drei Beitrag und viele weitere
müssten sie doch jetzt eigentlich sofort
aus der CDU ausschließen denn sie haben
jedem der mit der AFD zusammenarbeitet
sehr deutlich mit
Parteiausschlussverfahren gedroht ich
darf Sie mal zitieren ja nur für den
Zuschauern die Landesverbände vor allem
im Osten bekommen von uns eine glasklare
Ansage wenn irgendjemand von uns die
Hand hebt und mit der AFD zusammen zu
arbeiten dann steht am nächsten Tag ein
paar
Parteiausschlussverfahren an Zitat Ende
ich habe das auf dem kleinen Parteitag
der CDU am 16 Juni noch einmal
präzisiert und das war vielleicht auch
notwendig das zu präzisieren den
kommunalpolitik ist etwas anderes als
Landespolitik und Bundespolitik es geht
hier um gesetzgebende Körperschaften es
geht hier um regierungsbildungen
Auslöser war natürlich der Vorfall vor
einiger Zeit den Thüringen oder dann
Ministerpräsident gewählt worden ist mit
den Stimmen der FDP der CDU und der AFD
und dass sich das nicht wiederholt
dagegen richtet sich diese klare Ansage
auf Bundesebene Landesebene und es wird
keine Beteiligung der AFD an einer
Regierung gegeben jedenfalls nicht mit
uns und Sie werden auch keine mehr dafür
bekommen aber es geht doch auch in den
Gemeinden und politische Kooperation mit
einer ja zum Teil als rechtsextremen
geltende Partei das ist doch völlig klar
auf der kommunalen Ebene ist die
parteipolitisierung ohnehin ein bisschen
zu weit vorangeschritten es ist jetzt in
Thüringen ein Landrat gewählt worden und
natürlich ist das eine demokratische
Wahl es ist in Sachsen-Anhalt ein in
einer kleinen Gemeinde einen
Bürgermeister gewählt worden der AFD
gehört angehört und natürlich ist das
eine demokratische Wahl das haben wir
doch zu akzeptieren und natürlich muss
in den Kommunalparlamenten dann auch
nach Wegen gesucht werden wie man
gemeinsam die Stadt das Land den
Landkreis gestaltet die Zusammenarbeit
bezieht sich auf gesetzgebende
Körperschaften das betrifft übrigens
auch das Europäische Parlament in
deutschen Bundestag den Landtag ich habe
das in Bonn in Berlin am 16 Juni auch
noch mal sehr klar sehr deutlich gesagt
und da steht die klare Ansage wenn sich
jemand an dem Wort Brandmauer stellt ich
kann es sogar verstehen hinter dieser
Brandauer stehen nicht die Wähler
sondern in dieser stehen die Funktionäre
die man da als Träger mit denen wir in
die Parlamenten nicht zusammenarbeiten
werden aber die Wählerinnen und Wähler
der AFD die wollen wir natürlich
zurückgewinnen wenn es immer möglich ist
und vor allen Dingen wenn Sie unsere
Grundsätze Aktion das heißt mit Blick
auf die Basis ihrer eigenen Partei auf
der kommunalen Ebene haben Sie
eigentlich aufgegeben in einigen nein
ich habe das nicht aufgegeben sondern
wir sind doch selbstverständlich
verpflichtet demokratische Wahlen zu
akzeptieren und wenn dort das noch mal
ein Landrat ein Bürgermeister gewählt
wird der der AFD angehört ist es
selbstverständlich dass man nach Wegen
sucht wie man dann in dieser Stadt
weiter arbeiten kann kurz passend zum
Thema der sogenannte Chef der werteunion
Hans-Georg Maaßen sollte ja nach
Beschluss des Bundesvorstands
ausgeschlossen werden das zuständige
Kreispartei Gericht hat das kürzliche
war abgelehnt gehen Sie jetzt weiter in
die nächste Instanz das hängt davon ab
wie die Entscheidung begründet wird die
Gründe haben wir noch nicht wir haben
nur den Tenor aber nicht die Gründe und
die schauen wir uns in Ruhe an und dann
werden wir entscheiden
wenn man sich einmal die Umfragen in den
drei Bundesländern anschaut in denen im
kommenden Jahr gewählt wird dann liegt
die AFD überall vorne ihr
CDU-Abgeordneter Marko wanderwitz der
immerhin mal beauftragter war für die
der Bundesregierung für den Osten will
die AFD schlicht verbieten lassen
unterstützen sie seinen Vorschlag das
ist eine Einzelmeinung in der
Bundestagsfraktion die wir nicht teilen
parteivorte haben noch nie dazu geführt
dass man ein politisches Problem ist
dann bleiben wir noch einen Moment in
Thüringen dort ist die AFD ja aktuell
mit 33 34 % Umfragen nicht nur mit
weitem Abstand die stärkste Partei
sondern wenn man sich die Zahlen der
anderen Parteien anschaut kann eine
Regierung könnte eine Regierung ohne die
AFD ja nur gebildet werden wenn alle
Parteien kooperieren inklusive der linke
sie haben aber einen unvereinbarkeits
mit der Linkspartei müssten sie sich da
nicht öffnen
sie sprechen zu Recht im Konjunktiv die
Frage stellt sich im Augenblick nicht
und wir haben vor den drei
Landtagswahlen in Ostdeutschland noch
zwei große Landtagswahlen in
Westdeutschland nämlich in Hessen und
den Bayern und da liegt die Union die
CDU in Hessen die CSU in Bayern
klarfahren und dort kämpfen wir für
einen Regierungsauftrag und das ist die
Aufgabe der wir uns in diesem Jahr
stellen aber spielen wir das trotzdem
mal durch wenn die Verhältnisse so
bleiben in Thüringen was wäre wenn Herr
Koll wir werden das
uns anschauen und wir werden kämpfen
auch um Mehrheiten in Thüringen in
Brandenburg und den Sachsen in Sachsen
regiert Michael Kretschmer sehr
erfolgreich in einer schwierigen
Koalition wir kämpfen dafür dass das in
Brandenburg und in Thüringen auch
möglich ist und dann sehen wir weiter
schauen wir uns mal die Union an trotz
der ampelschwäche kommen sie eben selten
über die 28% Grenze sie selbst sagen das
ist der CDU bisher nicht gut gelungen
seit Themen zu setzen und das soll sich
jetzt erkennbar ändern wir haben es
erlebt der Parlamentarische
Geschäftsführer Thorsten Frey hat gerade
damit begonnen und hat wiederholt die
Abschaffung des individuellen Rechts auf
Asyl gefordert sie haben gesagt dass ein
guter und wichtiger Beitrag heißt das
sie unterstützen den Vorschlag 1:1 ich
unterstütze jeden Vorschlag der einen
Beitrag dazu leistet dieses Problem zu
lösen und das Thorsten frei damit nicht
allein steht auch nicht bei uns in
Deutschland zeigt einen Beitrag den
gerade heute in einer großen deutschen
Sonntagszeitung veröffentlicht worden
ist vom dänischen Minister für Ausländer
und Integration einem Sozialdemokraten
der genau denselben Vorschlag gemacht
wir müssen dieses Problem in Europa
lösen übrigens dann wird die AFD auch
wieder kleiner noch mal die Frage
unterstützen sie den freivorschlag für
eine sehr gut erwägenswerte Idee das ist
ein konstruktiver Beitrag wir werden das
in der Bundestagsfraktion auch noch mal
vertiefen wir werden dazu
Fachgespräche führen Experten einladen
wir wollen dieses Problem lösen und da
macht Thorsten frei
richtigerweise wie ich finde darauf
aufmerksam dass von diesem
Individualrecht auf Asyl im Augenblick
vor allem die profitieren die stark sind
junge Männer die sich auf diese
Flüchtlingsboote begeben können Frauen
ältere Menschen Kinder bleiben zurück
und das sind diejenigen die unsere Hilfe
wirklich brauchen er hat gestern noch
mal nachgelegt und den Vorschlag
erweitert und sogenannte pushbacks
befürwortet das heißt in internationalen
Gewässern aufgegriffene Menschen würden
dorthin zurückgebracht wo sie herkommen
das ist bisher nach internationalem
Recht weitgehend egal wie stehen Sie
dazu wirklich weitgehend illegal ist das
einmal dahingestellt Herr Kollege es
gibt auch Stimmen die genau seinen
Vorschlag für zulässig halten Pushback
sind eigentlich Begriffe aus dem
Grenzverkehr innerhalb der Europäischen
Union wenn also zum Beispiel jemand
deutsche Staatsgebiet erreicht hat wenn
man an der deutsch-polnischen Grenze und
er dann nach Polen zurückgebracht wäre
wir erleben vielen
Verordnungen wohl nicht zulässig aber
noch einmal wir müssen nach Wegen suchen
dieses Problem zu lösen und dieses
Problem wird nicht kleiner das wird
größer aber wie ist ihre Position dazu
mal losgelöst von der juristischen Seite
eine Position ist ganz einfach und sehr
klar die dass ich jeden Vorschlag
begrüße und für erwägenswert und
diskussionswürdig halte der zwei Dinge
erfüllt das Problem muss kleiner werden
und wir müssen unseren Menschenrecht
Verpflichtungen auf der Welt nach wie
vor Nachkommen wir müssen dabei bleiben
dass wir ein Land sind das auf der Welt
hilft aber diese Hilfe darf auch nicht
missbraucht werden und sie wird
hunderttausendfach missbraucht und
dagegen müssen was tun man hat ihre
Fraktion im März gerade ein
Positionspapier zu Asylpolitik
verabschiedet in dem eigentlich quasi
das Gegenteil steht tätig da heißt es
auf Seite 1 die Bundestagsfraktion ich
zitiere noch mal steht zum Grundrecht
auf Asyl für politisch Verfolgte und zu
den völkerrechtlichen Verpflichtungen
gemäß der Genfer Flüchtlingskonvention
also eigentlich das Gegenteil von dem
was frei ist das ist so nicht richtig es
gibt genügend Sachverständige
Völkerrechtler europarechtler die sagen
man kann das im Rahmen der bestehenden
Ordnung sowohl der Genfer
Flüchtlingskonvention als auch der
europäischen Regeln so machen wie
Thorsten freider
93 ohnehin nur noch eine sehr geringe
Rolle weil die meisten Flüchtlinge jetzt
nach der Genfer Flüchtlingskonvention
und noch den europäischen Regeln kommen
wir haben seit 1993 ohne ihn eine andere
Rechtslage also der Teil würde nicht
mehr gelten das Fraktions beschlossen
ist noch mal das ist kein Widerspruch
und dieser fraktionsbeschluss der ist
umfassend hat übrigens auch ein sehr
konkreten Vorschlag zur
Einwanderungspolitik in den Arbeitsmarkt
sehen wir der Bundesregierung schon
mehrfach vorgeschlagen haben wie man
dieses Problem der Einwanderung in
unseren Arbeitsmarkt besser lösen kann
und da sind wir schon Meinung dass man
das in Deutschland im Augenblick sehr
viel besser machen könnte
migrationsexperten gehen ja davon aus
dass es individuelle Recht auf Asyl
eigentlich nur wenige betrifft das
eigentliche Problem ist ja die illegale
Migration in die EU hessens
Ministerpräsident rein fordert daher
jetzt flächendeckende Kontrollen an
deutschen Außengrenzen sie auch ja das
ist eine Position die wir gemeinsam
haben es ist richtig die hessische CDU
hat das noch mal in einem eigenen
Positionspapier auch zu anderen Themen
klargestellt wir haben die
bundesinnenministerin mehrfach
aufgefordert das was zwischen Österreich
und Bayern schon passiert seit vielen
Monaten jetzt auch in anderen Teilen der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland zu
ermöglichen zum Beispiel im Grenzverkehr
zu Polen zum Beispiel im Grenzverkehr zu
Tschechien auch im Grenzverkehr zur
Schweiz wo ja auch
illegale Grenzübertritte stattfinden wir
müssen wenn wir die europäischen
Außengrenzen nicht gut schützen können
in der Lage sein die europäischen
Binnengrenzen unsere Staatsgrenzen zu
schützen wir müssen wissen wer nach
Deutschland kommt und ich meine das wäre
kein illegitimes Ansehen schauen wir mal
auf die zweite Kontur der vergangenen
Tage sie haben auf dem Posten des
Generalsekretärs ja den cda-mann Mario
Czaja setzt durch den
wirtschaftsliberalen Carsten Linnemann
wird es allgemein als konservatives
Signal gewertet der hat auch gleich
Schnellverfahren für freibadtäter
gefordert obwohl ja kennen wie auch
ihnen klar ist das justizpersonal fehlt
und B überwiegend jugendliche Täter ja
ungesetzlich es wäre ungesetzlich die
einen Schnellverfahren zu stehen diese
sogenannten Schnellverfahren heißen
beschleunigte Verfahren nach unserer
Strafprozessordnung und nach dem
Jugendgerichtsgesetz die sind möglich
sie werden übrigens erprobt in
Deutschland ich gebe Ihnen mal ein
Beispiel nachdem Krawallen die es ja
nicht nur in Berlin sondern z.B auch in
Baden-Württemberg gegeben hat über diese
westernacht dieses Jahres hat es in
Heilbronn eine ganze Reihe von Verfahren
innerhalb weniger Tage gegeben es sind
sogar wen die Frage danach Abschiebungen
vollzogen worden also das ist möglich es
geht nur für Täter ab 18 Jahren nicht
für Jugendliche also man muss volljährig
sein aber die sind zum Teil auch
volljährige Straftäter und da hat
Carsten Linnemann einen wichtigen Anstoß
gegeben ich teile das das geht das muss
möglich sein für Minderjährige nicht für
Minderjährige nicht aber für 18-Jährige
an aufwärts geht das sie haben bisher im
Bundestag wenn wir über Kontur der der
CDU in der Zukunft reden die meisten
Projekte der Ampel ja mitgetragen
jetzt erklären sie aber gleichzeitig die
Grünen zum Hauptgegner in der Ampel
obwohl hier zu Hause bei ihnen in
Nordrhein-Westfalen ein CDU
Ministerpräsident mit den Grünen regiert
und insgesamt sie ja in sechs
Landesregierung mit den Grünen sind was
wie passt denn das zusammen sagen
richtig gesagt ich habe die
Bundespolitik gemeint und nicht die
Landespolitik in der Tat die CDU regiert
in einigen Bundesländern gut mit den
Grünen zusammen aber wir richten uns
jetzt vor allen Dingen in der
Wirtschaftspolitik gegen das was aus dem
bundeswirtschafts Museum kommt was in
der Klimapolitik in der Energiepolitik
passiert wir machen konkrete
Gegenvorschläge das kann so nicht
bleiben und Herr Kollege jetzt müssen
wir mal über den Ernst der Lage reden
wir sind mitten in einem Prozess der
deinustrialisierung dieses Landes da
muss die Regierung jetzt schnell handeln
wir machen konkrete Vorschläge erstens
runter mit den energiebelastungen das
kann der Staat machen der braucht kein
energiepreisstrom für die Industrie
einzuführen der kann die Stromsteuer
Senken der kann die leitungsentgelte die
Netzentgelte Senken der kann die
Mehrwertsteuer senken auf Null auf Zeit
das geht wir könnten sofort Überstunden
Freistellen von Einkommensteuer wir
könnten aufhören mit diesen verboten und
die Verbote kommen insbesondere aus dem
Umweltministerium und aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium richtet sich
unsere Kritik aber sie wollen doch nicht
abstreiten dass auch in den Ländern
wichtige Politikbereiche gemacht werden
Millionen Signal an dem nein das ist
überhaupt nicht man kann mit den Grünen
in der Tat auf der Länderebene offenbar
ganz gut zusammenarbeiten wir haben das
in Berlin auch schon mal gekommen nur
wir sehen in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten dass sie sich immer stärker in
Regulierung und Verbote schauen sichern
Özdemir an der in seinem
Landwirtschaftsministerium nur noch über
Werbeverbote und und es Verbote
nachdenkt wir müssen raus aus diesen
ständigen verboten wir wollen Anreize
schaffen marktwirtschaftliche Anreize
ganz einfach soziale Marktwirtschaft
gegen grüne Planwirtschaft das ist die
Auseinandersetzung die wir im Augenblick
führen und die werden dafür führen
zum Schluss erlauben Sie mir einen
kurzen Blick in die Zukunft sie haben
wenn ich das sagen darf ist ja
öffentlich bekannt drei Kinder und
aktueller Stand fünf Enkel 6 sie sind
auf der Höhle der Zeit aber wunderbar
Glückwunsch sehen sie sich aktuell eher
als jemand der vor allem der nächsten
Generation die Güte die Bühne bereitet
und denen dann auch die Hauptrolle
zugesteht oder wäre das aus ihrer Sicht
in den nächsten Jahren ein zu früher
Verzicht auf eigene Talent und Erfahrung
das ist die netteste Form in der ich bis
heute nach der Kanzlerkandidatur gefragt
worden bin vielen Dank dafür es ist
beides richtig auch in meiner Generation
hat man die Pflicht natürlich
Vorbereitung zu treffen für nachfolgende
Generation aber auch selbst noch
Verantwortung zu übernehmen und genau
das mache ich auch in den nächsten
Jahren ich bin bis Ende 2025 hier in
diesem Wahlkreis für den Deutschen
Bundestag gewählt und selbstverständlich
mache ich das den Ministerpräsident von
Nordrhein-Westfalen hatte ja passend zu
dem Thema vergleichsweise deutlich seine
weitergehenden Ambitionen kundgetan sie
haben dann bei uns in der Sendung bei
Berlin direkt ziemlich heftig darauf
reagiert warum
ich habe das einmal klargestellt das war
etwas überraschend was da am 15 und 16
Juni passiert war aber das ist
ausgeräumt und erledigt hier Biograph
wird
so zitiert märz ist sehr intelligent
rhetorisch begabt aber hat so etwas wie
ein sympathieproblem wird am Ende der
beste Kanzlerkandidat oder der mit den
besten Chancen die Wahl zu gewinnen das
entscheiden wir gemeinsam in der Union
wir haben uns vorgenommen dass im
Spätsommer 2024 zu tun bis dahin müssen
wir hart arbeiten und ich will es noch
mal sagen wir müssen Vertrauen
zurückgewinnen dass wir verloren haben
und daran arbeiten wir jeden Tag wir
führen keine personaliskussion
er hat sich danke Ihnen für das Gespräch
danke
das war unser Sommer Interview mit dem
CDU-Vorsitzenden am kommenden Sonntag
trifft meine kolleginischer bernaji den
Chef der Linkspartei Martin in Apolda
Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend und eine
gute Woche
[Musik]